vous avez trois tigres heures ou trois
tigresses en fait où vous avez une
tigresse blanche
keira est là bas vous avez une lionne
couleurs formes et unyon blanche donc
mara emma fric il les appelle tendrement
ses filles pour michael douchet ces
animaux sont comme des enfants qu'il
faut élever et dont il faut prendre soin
chaque jour il passe du temps avec eux
dans la cage de détente une aire de jeux
et de repos leur territoire michael est
le seul à y être toléré il est considéré
comme le mâle dominant la salle armed
and hunters reconnaître l'effort savoir
l'accident avant qu'elle arrive
michael connaît chacun de leur caractère
et de leur aptitude un savoir qui lui a
permis de préparer son spectacle c'est
comme se dresser sur des pattes arrière
et qu'ils le font naturellement on les
voit faire on regarde ce qu'est ce
qu'ils peuvent faire et c'est là où on
apprend à faire des spectacles
donc il faut venir vraiment faire
comprendre passer du temps avec eux et
y'a vraiment qu'avec des récompenses et
de la douceur qu'on arrive à faire plein
de choses
née au sein de la famille douchet du
cirque nicolas zavatta michael a baigné
depuis l'enfance au plus près des félins
avec son grand frère dompteur fasciné
par ces animaux ils commençaient premier
spectacle à 14 ans aujourd'hui à 26 ans
il fait toujours partie des plus jeune
dompteur d'europe
quelques heures avant le spectacle les
artistes répètent un plat salé mais les
femelles sont encore des adolescentes
âgées de 1 à 6 ans parfois un peu
turbulente et pas toujours très à l'aise
ma fric est encore en phase
d'apprentissage alors l'afrique va pas
sauter
allez maintenant saute parfois nous l'y
carrasso si ça marche plus une confiance
instaurée dès le plus jeune âge tous nés
en captivité certains fauves ont été
élevés au biberon quand la mère ne
voulait pas d'eux une éducation basée
sur la confiance et un système de
récompenses en morceaux de viande et en
caresse pour ceux qui les aiment comme
koumaye depuis un mois
le spectacle commence bientôt tout doit
être prêt car c'est michael et ses
fauves qui ouvre le bal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le reste de la représentation se
poursuit et se termine avec ou my
michael contenu le spectacle car c'est
lui qui s'occupe de toute la ménagerie
du cirque une passion et un métier
souvent mal vu c'est vraiment une vie au
quotidien
on vit avec eux comme on vit avec nos
enfants ont donc on les aime on fait
tout pour qu'il soit le mieux possible
c'est vrai que j'écoute parfois dire des
choses il serait mieux dans la nature il
sera mieux on peut dire plein de choses
ici nous ont fait le mieux possible pour
qu'il soit bien on leur donne à manger
autant qu'ils en veulent tout le monde
peut venir voir justement où son dernier
mot et commençons à privilégier le
dialogue et le partage pour désamorcer
les tensions le cirque traditionnel avec
des animaux inventé il ya 250 ans reste
toujours un spectacle très demandé un
art à part entière interdit dans des
pays comme le danemark ou le mexique
un métier qu'il transmettra aux
générations suivantes si la législation
française le permet